hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and AH just checking in on you
I'm just checking in on you how's it
going how's your Thursday how's your
week you having a good time out there
you're getting ready to eat your [__]
face off hey well here's a good one for
you you know you can eat like an
absolute Pig on Thanksgiving you know
you're gonna eat all the leftovers and
all that crap you know you're gonna
drink your face off that win the
Wednesday before Thanksgiving going out
there right trying to meet some leg all
right going back to your hometown you
know you're gonna do all of that crap is
I just the windscreen here on the
microphone you know you gonna do all
that [__] so why not why not before why
not now just you do cardio every [__]
day giant salad right you got a giant
salad with the protein somewhere in your
[__] day lunch or dinner why don't
you do that right up until Thanksgiving
you know and right through the
Thanksgiving weekend why don't you just
do that every day say I'm gonna get on
that [__] [__] elliptical and
knock out a half-hour why don't you do
that instead of eating yourself into a
food coma and then you're gonna have all
that sugar and salt in you and you know
what you're gonna be thinking I should
work out and all that [__] stuff is
going to be sitting on your brain gum no
working out is hard [__] near becoming a
fat [__] is easy yes it is easy anything
worth anything worth something in life
it's difficult come on guys what are we
doing here huh
aren't we fat enough how much longer
America are we gonna sit here and gloat
how much poisonous food we have more
poisonous food than any other nation on
the planet you know how much longer it's
not even really point I think most of it
now that I'm starting to watch these
things on nutrition is how they just had
the whole thing upside down and the
whole food pyramid was created by a guy
who didn't know [__] about food who went
to [__] Italy post-world War two were
they lost do bunch goddamn nerds
Italy lost at they lined up with [__]
a star over there right Adolf Hitler
right they lined up with him and they
lost so he went over to a [__]
war-torn country post war right
everybody was [__] broke so everyone
was skinny and he equated it to their
[__] diet and started talking about
how you want to eat a bunch of
carbohydrates like these [__] guys
who lost a goddamn war not tell you
something like that I don't know I'll
post a video but all I know is like all
that stuff is like the devil I still
cannot get my head around the fact that
I can eat this much meat and I still
don't I think you know I guess as my
mother always said everything in
moderation she would yell across the
room right so I guess that's what you
want to do so I'm just kidding I'm gonna
do what the [__] I always do I do a ton
of goddamn cardio and I stop beating
around five o'clock six o'clock and then
I just crushed the waters one of the
meals is a [__] salad that's what I
do all right that's how I lose weight I
don't sit around blaming society or the
[__] industry I'm in right is I'm
eating a [__] candied apple it's like
a lot of these [__] people out there
that if just
give it in to their sugar salt coma and
then want you to sit there and accept
their defeat rather than standing up and
giving them a halftime [__] speech you
know grabbing him by that back of their
hair and pulling it out of that bowl of
[__] peanut and [__] chocolate
M&Ms and getting right in that grill
like Bobby Knight used to poking them in
the chest you know talking to them about
that transition game between one male to
another that's what's happening out
there right this cut this [__]
country's getting it's getting soft
it's getting soft everybody's a goddamn
[__] victim everybody has a [__]
excuse right and everybody's letting
them get away with it going like now now
now now all right it's not the potato
chips fault it's your fault
all right you control your hands stop
telling your hands to go into the bag
all right if you weight a head of
lettuce the way you eat those [__]
chips like I'm telling you right now
you'd be a goddamn drink boat you know
what you got to do quit your [__]
crying all right I'm done you know what
song is in my head when I wanna I was
just talking I'm in the middle of a
radio tour right now promoting my dates
in Albuquerque and in Arizona I don't
know where the hell I'm gonna be in
Arizona Tucson or some [__] and then I
got Hollywood Florida and I have Orlando
Florida well I will be going to the
Orlando Magic game the last team I need
to see protein that I need to see in the
state of Florida plus I've seen the
Miami Hurricanes and the Florida Gators
what's left you ask the Florida State
Seminoles you know in a central florida
keeps making noise I got I got to go
down there eventually right I don't know
I guess what's left is to [__] try to
swim Lake Okeechobee whatever the hell
it is and try not to get eaten by an
alligator or maybe the Python that ate
the [__] alligator I don't I don't
pretend to understand these things I
don't I don't try to pretend to
understand what Florida is but whatever
I was just in the middle of this radio
tour and I was joking around
[__] guy that was interviewing me and
somehow we started singing that song
brandy remember that song brandy was a
[__] [__] and Depp óbuda doin her
[__] it's but he said they're hitting
on up pirate and he never would commit
to her that's such a sad song when you
really listen to the [__] lyrics it's
like she sounds like such a nice woman
why doesn't she get out of that [__]
bar and stop talking to those those
those Whalers whatever the hell she's
talking to their job takes them out to
sea I did one cruise ship in my entire
career I have never been further away
from anything that I knew or loved in my
life you know people go on cruises to
get rid of their spouse you know when
they went through with the marriage that
they didn't want to be in and rather
than just looking at everybody just
saying I don't want to do this and just
let everybody Pelt you with the wedding
cake next thing you know you're laying
in your little [__] cabin on a cruise
ship going like all right so I'll uh
I'll tell it I'm gonna take a picture of
our else oh my god it's just the [__]
that people do happens to guys two
people fall overboard in those things
why am I talking about cruise ships I
don't even know why oh yeah so why would
this woman commit to these [__]
people you know they always make it out
like she's the victim I think what
really happened was I think Brandi
didn't want a relationship you know
maybe that's what it was I just feel
like for me all right so I'm 91 days
into not drinking I'm in overtime right
now the movie is wrapped basically done
with my gigs for this year I'm chilling
out I'm getting into the holiday spirit
Oh Billy the Baker's gonna rear his ugly
head I think I'm gonna make a blueberry
pie this year you know I'm gonna
deep-fry a [__] turkey but my wife
won't let me buy the apparatus why can't
we just order one I don't know because
it's not as fun it's not that sense of
satisfaction knowing that somebody else
made the [__] turkey what kind of man
am I gonna have somebody else cooked my
[__] turkey I mean doesn't that sound
borderline filthy
that's like something if you whispered
it in a woman's ear at work I mean you
have a [__] problem here you deep-fry
my turkey for me [__] did you just say
to me all right I don't but you know I'm
getting to this point that I'm starting
to understand like there's this weird
balance you have to have when you're
married you have to say exactly what the
[__] you're thinking you have to be
honest with your partner while totally
agreeing with everything that they say I
haven't figured it out yet
you know maybe it's a friend's account a
brunch do you want to go no no I don't
why because it's always crowded it's
always crowded you go down there you got
to stand there then you're standing
outside waiting for them to [__] call
your name and then when they finally
call your name you're sitting there
eating has all these other people are
eyeballing your plate breathing down
your [__] neck from across the room
it's like the food version of playing
golf is there anything worse than
playing golf and you got that [__]
you got those goddamn borderline prose
of playing right behind you you just see
them just [__] like 80 yards away
like throwing their hands up like Jesus
Christ how many [__] attempts do you
need it's that same kind of pressure
it's just like I [__] play through
eat through buddy you want to sit down
in order I'll [__] pick my plate up I
know somewhere now is being honest with
my wife so you know don't you like me
anymore it's like lady I married you I'm
paying all the bills okay what more that
this whole thing crumbles over some
[__] eggs and I don't want to go down
and get we got eggs in the fridge
sweetheart why don't you bring your
friends over here they'll sit out on the
back porch cuz you want to get dressed
up we want to go out and look cute and
have other women resent us for how cute
we are look at that speech yourself
they're being cute and so [__] mad at
them alright so now that I'm back
I ordered the NHL in the NBA package as
of yesterday I watched my first NHL game
why at a why yesterday
Bruins versus the Anaheim Ducks and if
you were rootin for the Bruins what a
[__] stinker I know we're really
banged up in that type of thing but
Jesus Christ the one problem the Boston
Bruins have had ever since they decided
to blow up the team is we lack that
[__] power forward that person that is
on the ice that everybody else has to be
like oh [__] keep your head on a goddamn
swivel so-and-so's out there every team
if you want to compete in the NHL you
got to have that it's like a [__]
great white shark just swimming around
everybody's just hoping the thing just
got done eating you know what I mean you
always keeping an eye out where the [__]
is that thing
you know those great white sharks they
just they just swim so goddamn slowly
until POW they [__] turn it on next
thing you know you got [__] 90 rows
of teeth coming at you right you're all
drunk swimming naked out to a buoy
whatever the [__] it is you're doing at
the beginning to just we don't have that
ever since we got rid of Lucic and I
don't think that those people come I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say those
guys are very few and far between we got
to have our guy who's our enforcer I
don't even know and I looked at the
Celtics roster as I mentioned it's like
I knew every everybody on the Celtics
and now I know like three of them they
got rid of everybody but I heard they're
playing great and I believe they have a
game tonight so I'm gonna watch that and
I also want to say the Bruins are
playing back-to-back down here I think
they're playing the Kings these are
always brutal games Bruins always come
out here and [__] loose I can't
believe the Kings it took him so goddamn
long to win this many games all these
years everybody comes down here and once
just party in Hollywood and try to [__]
a movie star that's what everybody's
doing right so then they come to the
game all hungover right smelling like
the flavor of the month whoever the [__]
they just banged and then they go in
there and they just walked through the
game and they get their [__] asses
kicked this is what happens every
goddamn time but at least you can go
down to
Anaheim and beat the Ducks right the
these equally injured Ducks but we we
couldn't get it done
we couldn't infect the Ducks have won
the last eight regular-season games
against the Bruins they [__] onus a
team we're an original 16 getting owned
by a team that's made after a Disney kid
movie how [__] sad is that I have no
idea so anyways I'm just gonna keep
going with this streak I'm not gonna get
to at least a hundred days and then see
how I feel but if I go through the end
of the year I'll have four solid months
that I didn't drink so that's like a
third of the year which for most people
would be good but if you saw the level
with which I abused alcohol just
slapping it all over all over the room I
would feel better if that number was up
around six but um as I've mentioned I am
turning 50 next year and I'm gonna be
[__] I'm going sting in my 50s I want
to try to anyways I might regret telling
you guys that I'm doing that but I'm
telling you if I can ever get [__]
healthy
I got another injury alright listen to
this I did inside the NFL which you can
watch this week on Showtime right and
now doing this show I'm having a great
time you know it was [__] hilarious I
was in the greenroom and I walk in in it
and Ray Lewis is there and I start
telling him how I scalped a ticket to go
to a Ravens game I've told this story
before I scalped a ticket and I go in
and I sit down I'm like holy [__] this
is I could like announce the game from
where I'm sitting and I'm like this is
one of the best Scout tickets I ever
gotten for a great price and all of a
sudden the security guy just goes excuse
me sir I've been said for about you know
half hour is that your seat do you have
to take of it and I go yeah yeah it is
he goes oh great could you come out to
the aisle for a second so I can't my
looks my ticket goes yeah that is your
that is your seat where did you get this
ticket and I was like I scalped it
outside he goes okay I understand I
understand
can you just come down the stairs for a
second so I come down the stairs now
there's another security personnel
there's two security people I
can you describe the person that you
bought this ticket off of I'm like I
don't know you got a shirt I know it's
gonna go uh no it's just we just have
some questions can you walk down this
aisle
can you come like underneath so now
we're underneath the thing and if I just
say the guy go look can you quit kicking
me out of the stadium ten feet at a time
what's going on here and then the guy
goes well these were stolen these are
season tickets and they were stolen out
of one of our season ticket holders
mailboxes so this is a stolen ticket I
go oh so what so I'm screwing they go no
no no what we're gonna try to see if you
know we can get you another ticket bla
bla and they will get me all the way
downstairs now I'm right next to the to
like the side door and I go can you get
me another ticket they're like yeah
unfortunately not and then they just
kicked me out the whole thing was they
didn't want me to flip out and scream
and yelling for everybody the [__]
NFL is just something such [__] god
forbid there's an issue right so I'm
telling the guys there the story they
were all laughing so I went out and I
scalped I actually was so mad that I was
getting kicked out that I said the
[__] scalper was a tall skinny white
dude it was actually a short black guy
and I don't even know why I did that
I was just so [__] mad I didn't want
to help anybody out so I went back
outside scalped another ticket
I paid even more money now I'm sitting
in the lower deck and I said yeah and I
go that and they're all laugh and listen
to the story and go yeah that's the game
that it was against Cleveland that was
the game with that dude on the Browns
ran for like 300 yards and set the
rushing record and all of a sudden Ray
Lewis just he dropped his head a little
bit and he just starts staring at me and
I'm laughing I'm going sorry man that
guy put up like 295 yards because what
are you talking about I got Danny did he
run and then he goes then he goes now
because that was our guy I forget he
said the guy's name he goes he ran for
like 295 and I said oh I'm sorry my bad
that I laugh I go Jesus Christ dude you
were [__] looking at me he went all
full-metal-jacket and everyone just
started laughing dude Ray Lewis is like
the [__] coolest guy ever and he's
still like if you saw how like hurt he
was that I would ever suggest that
anyone put
close to 295 yards on a Ravens defense
that he was a part of I got to ask all
those guys so many cool questions I
actually I asked Ray Lewis if he had a
ha you know what's it like being one of
the great linebackers of all time
watching how these linebackers you know
get to just soda I mean the wide
receivers just to kind of get to skip
down the damn field now and he goes ah
he goes I can't I have a hard time
watching he goes I got to take like
blood pressure medicine I'm like walking
around watching the game so anyways
we're we're in between segments and they
actually did this segment on like how
the guys on defense don't know what they
can and can't get away with so they're
playing timid and these wide receivers
and quarterbacks and running backs are
having a field day out there
so of course Boomer Esiason is siding
with the offense and everyone on the
show was siding with that that it that's
over-policed and blah blah blah blah
blah so anyway so that segment ends and
boomers continue in the conversation he
goes did you see what happened to Aaron
Rodgers and he goes the guy came over he
pin boomer walks over and it goes to
pick me up and I don't know why I should
have said boomer I saw the play so he
goes to pick me up you know when you go
to pick somebody up what you do is you
pull him in towards you and you put the
pressure of you lifting them up across
their back he didn't he tried to pick me
up from my sides and like crush my rib
cage and you just hear it I just heard
you just heard something pop on my right
side and he goes oh [__] he put me down
and he and I go I don't know why I just
go I think that was my back and he goes
really it sounded like your ribs and I
knew instantly that he [__] me up he I
know what the [__] he did to my obliques
it's not like some lifelong [__] you
know what I mean I'm not a millennial
I'm not gonna sue anybody this is just
like four days epson salt bath but like
I knew immediately he [__] me up and
if somehow somebody sends this to him I
want him to know that when I sit here it
doesn't hurt but I my car down at UH in
alley yesterday trying to like beat this
traffic
and it had all these potholes so like
the suspension was rocking back and
forth so I was going side to side and I
had to use my obliques I was just going
down the alley going like ah but I'm
good because I can laughs right now so
it feels fine but uh yes you know it
would have been such a cooler story if
it was Rayleigh Ray Lewis who did it to
me as opposed to a quarterback but
here's the deal he's still like six four
and all of those guys have like [__]
gorilla strength and I'm just a comedian
and my baby blue sweater anyway so how
funny is that I actually went on a
[__] football program with ex NFL
players and came out of there with an
injury I'm like day to day right now I
would still start on Sunday if we were
playing football they'd spray it was
something but anyways I had such a great
time with all of those guys and Ray
Lewis Nate and boomer I had such a great
time on that whole thing and of course
JB we were all teasing him about his
haircut I don't know if it made it but I
said he looked like Count Basie and they
would trasher me for being bald and all
of that it was just I wish I lived in
New York that's how much fun I had on
that show but also I also realized like
how little football I watched when I was
on there like when I had to pick the
teams like I had no idea what anybody's
doing you know my daughter's crawled
she's starting to stand up at this point
I mean that alone I could barely pay
attention and I was in the writers room
and then immediately went down to the
acting gig so my apology I mean of all
the [__] years for me to get back on
that show the one year I think next year
I'm gonna get to watch a lot more but I
was sitting there like before I went on
the show like trying to study up like
you know the day before you finally you
know you're not going to pass but you're
just trying to get a respectable
flunking grade and you know even after
all that's studying I have no idea what
the [__] is gonna win it I know the
Eagles and the Rams are doing well as
other Vikings and and even though the
Patriots are 7 and 2 I never believed in
our defense I just don't think we get
enough pressure on the [__]
quarterback and they seem to be able to
do pretty well against our
secondary this year so we'll see I don't
know but anyways thank you to everybody
over there for having me on inside the
NFL please watch it this week they gave
me [__] about deflategate and I of
course took the bait once again I always
take the bait
I should have just been like hey man you
know [__] I got five reasons to not
get upset holding up all five fingers
for the five rings we got and I never
thought to do that I mean so anyway so I
did the [__] show and then
immediately I went down to I went right
to the airport because I wanted to see
get onto my family my family over with
my family back west out west you go back
east and you go out west and I get to
Newark Airport and I'm hungry and I
quickly realized there's no way to get
food in the air I flew United and the
entire [__] terminal when you showed
up wherever you went to sit down to eat
if there's any sort of sit down and
eating you had to be your own waiter you
had to interact with this [__] iPad
and the second I sit down I'm looking at
my face on the screen I'm like what the
[__] is this so I cover the camera with
my wallet and the lady comes over I do
you know anything I'm like I'm not a
waiter sweetheart I don't work at this
restaurant why am I being why do I'm you
know and I was being a dick to her and
everything in the end I tipped her in
cash though I did I said listen I'm not
upset with you I'm just upset with this
[__] apparatus here I like human
beings okay
and I don't like this thing you know
filming me here she goes that's not
filming you it's just gonna take a
picture your ticket it's like what the
[__] does Wendy's give a [__] about what
what airline I'm flying on you're
gathering information and you just sit
there and act like this thing isn't
filming me they're gonna be like white
male looks to be about this old ordered
the fried chicken sandwich and they're
gonna use just take it it's constantly
sucking this [__] information out
about you so just sit down don't scan
your [__] ticket they're gonna use all
that information like oh no we're just
trying to you know if it's getting too
close and your your your plane is
boarding and blah blah blah they're not
that's what they're doing on one side
but on the other side there
figuring out what race what sex what you
ordered where you live how you dressed
all of this [__] information so you
can get bombarded with even more [__]
you know I don't know even more
advertising however if you just
committed a murder and you think that
you know by them filming you there and
that's a good alibi then bought by all
means don't cover it but um I don't the
whole thing is [__] annoying to me
and next time I go to Newark Airport I'm
just gonna make sure I eat before I get
there cuz this guy old freak this
freckled [__] he ain't playing ball
alright and with that let me read some
advertising before the next person calls
me here oh look who it is but up up me
undies me undies stop taking my picture
on an iPad but dude dude dude me undies
me undies I'm not happy I'm [__] mad
why am i working for your [__] joint
who gives a [__] I I don't know I don't
even [__] know I'm sorry I just
tapped out of that thing lately I just
been picking words that don't even if I
can't rhyme them
joint I don't [__] work here that's
my point bring a lady out here to take
my order and explain what the [__] I'm
doing I'm not a millennial oh no you
can't have my social security number
alright me undies everybody me undies
let me tell you about me undies the only
underwear that makes for an amazing gift
me undie is soft flexible like the [__]
up the street and three to three times
softer than cotton me undies makes the
perfect gift you know what they should
come out with horse muzzle underwear you
know what I mean soft is a horse muzzle
up against your privates me undies makes
the perfect gift it's the goddamn
holidays this year don't give underwear
give me undies this holiday season to
get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you will ever wear
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies calm / /
that's me undies calm / / oh we look at
this we only have one more left we only
got one more left saathi everybody meow
everyone at some point has wished they
could just have a beer wine or liquor
delivered
well someone finally decided to do
something about well why stop there why
not bring some coke and some wheat
introducing Stassi meow the alcohol
delivery app saucy Oriole delivers your
favorite wine beer and liquor right -
you do on demand it's uber for alcohol
did you wake up face down still wearing
the clothes from last night and have too
big a headache but you can still reach
for the phone and you want a little hair
of the dog
saucy is the app for you now if you're
in Los Angeles San Francisco Chicago San
Diego or Sacramento your saucy order
will arrive at your door in 30 minutes
or less ready to drink for the rest of
us
saucy will deliver beer wine and liquor
[Music]
wine in liqueur toe your door I don't
know what the [__] copy this is in two
days or less nationwide hey guys get
your Thanksgiving order in now there are
no premiums no delivery fees no running
to the store if you got the saucy app
you've got a fully stocked bar on your
phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download this thought
the app and enter promo code bar that's
the saucy app spelled sau cey and enter
promo code bur for $15 off get the saucy
app today use promo code ber all right
there you go see that I had to sit up
and I was on my side [__] I already got
a missed call okay I got to get back to
this radio - alright that's that's the
Thursday afternoon just checking in oh
no that was some 30 minutes ago I think
I'm good just checking in on you [__]
podcast here what else I got another two
minutes here don't I I got another two
minutes unless somebody [__] calls me
here what else what else is there to
talk about I'm gonna go to my little
studio space and play my drums today
the first time and like I think like
three weeks gonna see if I remember how
to do it but I've been hitting the
practice pad pretty hard getting back to
taking some lessons I'm gonna be that
[__] guy I this is what I want this
one I won't be able to do on drums all
right if I hear it I want to be able to
play it and then my technique I want not
even have to think about it and have my
forearms everything's nice and relaxed
relaxed sitting up straight just one of
those [__] guys and then I can
actually see you know if I actually have
any sort of talent for the goddamn
instrument that is my goal in 2018 all
right
and that's it okay somebody's gonna be
calling me any second here and I'm gonna
have to promote one of my gigs but oh I
know what I gotta tell you I'm doing a
gig for Puerto Rico don't gig for Puerto
Rico the Monday before Thanksgiving at
the Laugh Factory down in Long Beach
okay this is a very important gig
because what happened out there was
devastated and our president just
brought paper towels that's all that
happened let me see if I can get you
this information here where is my where
is my account
I haven't tweeted that much have I
profile I go to the profile I scroll
down I scroll down it won't let me of
course tweets how do I find out I click
on my picture I slide over okay here we
go scrolling down scrolling down it'll
burn where's the [__] that I tweeted I
don't know I'll get you all the
information as far as snow wait I'll
look up I look up cranes [__] here hang
on one second hang on hang on hang out
just [__] relax alright here we go
alright no Monday November 20th
look who's here what's up buddy what's
up buddy please don't touch my laptop
how you doing
Monday November 20th I'm doing a benefit
for the people of Puerto Rico all the
information will be on my website and
here's the next phone call
alright I was looking at my daughter and
I almost said to you guys I love you
guys to death no I need to say to you
guys go after yourself
I love my daughter did that look at you
cutie all right don't join the music
I'll check in on you and Thursday though
this is start I'll see you Monday
[Music]
Farmar wealthy or they were so lovely
cookie does you see do I love you Gemma
[Music]
commanded you
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday November 16 2009 and I'm actually
recording this at 12 noon on a Sunday
what do you think about that how do you
like that
for forward [__] thinking you like
that I anticipated that Monday was
coming on Sunday and I got the [__]
thing out of the way so right now you're
listening to it you a little cubicle oh
my god he actually got it done on time I
just so exciting it [__] hate my job
it's [__] 9:00 in the morning my boss
is the [__] and I get to listen to this
and act like I'm looking at spreadsheets
there you go I finally did it
every once in a while I come through for
the people on the East Coast and you
might be asking yourself why bill why we
so motivated I'll tell you why because
for some [__] reason I have been go
I've been I've been going to sleep like
a little old lady this week you know you
ever just get in one of those weird
sleep patterns where right after the
evening news you know you watch a little
bit of Jeopardy you slip off your
loafers so you sit there on the
Davenport trying to think of some
[__] old people terms here I don't
know when I've been going to bed like at
9:30 10:00 and then I've been getting up
at 6:00 in the morning like a farmer you
know like a farmer I just said that
because I know this farmers out there
it'll probably listen to this actually
we get up at 4:00 in the morning do we
[__] good really good for you what
time do you go to bed you know that all
[__] works out doesn't it I'm
speaking of farmers I actually saw a
Food Inc this week because some podcast
listener I wanted to say that real close
podcast listener recommended it and the
classic give and take care of the Monday
morning podcast I learned a little thing
you little learn a little thing I say
[__] you everybody laughs
somebody told me to rent that that
documentary Food Inc and let me tell you
it was very very interesting very
interesting to see where the food comes
from and what exactly goes on to the
food before the food gets to my table
and which is why this morning I want I
got up so early to go to a farmers
market I wanted to go where the with the
local guys make it you know where they
let the chickens run free before they
murder them this is a free-range chicken
it had a [__] wonderful seven weeks
on this planet before we stuck it in the
funnel and sliced its throat actually
had video of how they kill the chickens
that's what they they stick them in
these little uh the the the down-home
farmers the regular old farmer wasn't
given into the man dude they got like
you ever see like those fancy Baker's
right as opposed to the blue-collar
Baker's who got those fat little thumbs
the fancy Baker's when they go to make
one of those those uh
cakes for some fancy [__] douchebag
who's probably a slumlord right you know
when they go to put the frosting on you
know that little [__] reverse trumpet
thing that they use why am i going so
far look at do you remember you ever see
back in the day the original football
games when they're like
rah-rah-sis-boom-bah they were yelling
through that little [__] that little
[__] funnel thing it had a handle on
it I know you guys know what I'm talking
about well they have those and they they
have like the part you know the part
where you yell into that's on that would
be like Jesus how can I explain this
picture if you had one of those
rah-rah-sis-boom-bah things right and
you wanted to yell up to the heavens and
you [__] [__] to your neck back and
the thing was going straight up that's
the way they have these things and they
have them in a circle like like ten
silver ones and they take these chickens
and they [__] stick them in headfirst
so they go right down the [__]
and then their little chicken head
sticking out the bottom and they're like
all and then they [__] slice their
throat and they bleed him out that's how
they do it on the regular old farms
that's how they do it and the other ones
more industrial once they don't quite do
it that way so watch out Food Inc check
it out you know at the end it's a bunch
of [__] dead animals but uh I don't
know I like clean food call me crazy but
I like clean food so anyways I was
supposed to get up you know early this
morning I've been all excited all this
week cuz you know me I see one little
thing that says a corporation is [__]
me over and then that becomes my quest
for that week you know it's why I don't
talk on my cell phone anymore it's why I
don't trust banks
it's why I'm not a Democrat or a
Republican it all comes down to some
[__] video that some fat [__] living
in his mother's basement has made and I
just take it his loss
that's how I do it okay and so the whole
week I've been obsessed with going to
the [__] farmers market and every day
I've been going we're going right we're
going and finally yesterday my girl
couldn't take any more and she's like
yes we're going you know when they get
that okay they get like that [__]
tone in their voice and I was just like
what a douche was my immediate thought I
just turned around and walked out
because you can't slap them even though
they deserve it sometimes at least he
could throw something at them you know
something that's in between nerf in a
blunt object what would that be you know
beyond a pillow but not quite the
refrigerator door how about a soft
covered book isn't that and you know
frisbee it Adam cuz that might catch the
corner in their eye what you do is you
sort of lob it at them you know like a
Robert Parish foul shot half that not
the rainbow sort of like a half rainbow
you know and it just lands on them the
[__] meaty part of their thigh makes
that a nice slap sound anyways yes if
she annoys the [__] out of me right
again I got okay a typical broad acting
like I'm being a [__] douchebag right
and what happens this morning she's four
can sleep in like boxcar Willie until
like 11:00 in the morning and she
clearly told me like [__] months ago
that you have to get over there early
because if you don't get over there
early enough there's just gonna be a
bunch of strawberries laying on the
sidewalk you know so she finally gets up
right she finally gets up around she's
in the other room so I have to whisper
here she finally gets up around [__]
11:00 you know I'll sleep yeah Josiah ah
and she knows she [__] up she knows it
I know it the downstairs neighbor knows
it everybody knows she's [__] up why
did she [__] up because she overslept
now she [__] up because she was a
douche the day before acting like I was
overreacting like that way I gotta
[__] go and what does she do she goes
out she has a couple of pops and next
thing you know she sleeps till [__]
11 alright and you're probably like what
bill why didn't you go in there wake
wake her up oh I'll tell you why because
she's been breaking my balls about how I
keep going to bed at 9:30 and then I
start puttering around like some War
veteran at 5:00 in the morning this
whole [__] week so I let her sleep
thinking maybe she get up at 9:00 maybe
she hit up at 9:30 maybe ten at ten I
just said you know what who gives a [__]
I've been eating corn-fed beef fill my
whole [__] life you know I'm still
walking around I'll do it for another
week who gives a [__] right since she
wakes up 11 she said I was like no no
we're not I go cuz you told me all this
[__] was is gone if you don't get there
early so why do I want to go over there
now I also like going over there earlier
because I'm a redhead and we live in a
desert and I don't feel like standing
out in the middle of the [__] street
at 11 o'clock in the morning plus the
football games are already on so then
what does she do you know the typical
codependent [__] she keeps trying to get
me to go with her well there's still
gonna be some stuff left they'll have
kale they'll have some broccoli yeah I
don't give a [__] I was going over there
for the meat that's what that's what I
was doing so you can't come with me no
iearnt stay away come with me that
[__] nightmare I just refused to
[__] go I'd gotten on with my day
I started paying my bills for Monday I
was gonna do the podcast I'm gonna go
[__] work out and of course the
second I started this podcast who comes
walking in the door my girl comes
walking in and informs me that there was
still plenty of [__] left which is still
not my fault I went by her information
that nothing would be left and for all I
know she's [__] lying you know there
was plenty of stuff left he could have
come with me [__] so that's been my
[__] morning and I also realized that
my [__] Patriots don't play until 8
o'clock at night which is 5 o'clock out
here at 5:30 so so I had not better to
do I decided I'd do a [__] podcast
rather than sitting here doing nothing
when she came home because then she
could have been like well why didn't you
come with me um anyways let's this is
the Monday morning podcast did any of
that make any [__] sense was that
just a classic boring [__]
relationship story did I just bore you
for [__] nine minutes and 33 seconds
well I hope you I hope I did because
I've been getting too many complaints
about the [__] podcast lately I liked
it back in the day you were more angrier
bill do it on your cell phone again you
know whoever's wrote me that you know
what did you used to do why don't you go
do that why don't you stop evolving as a
[__] human being and just do it the
way you did it two years ago
we're the same [__] shirt you know
what I mean you want it the exact same
way every [__] you know [__] idiots
do it I like their new stuff I like
their first two albums I don't like to I
don't like when they changed don't you
like people were into bands like that
like people who are into like [__] u2
you know people just can't [__]
respect for the fact that that they've
continued to [__] evolve and put out
killer songs change their sound come
back to their sound divert from it
become huge rock stars mock being huge
rock stars always coming up with a new
way to make it a little bit different
there always has to be that [__]
douchebag going I liked him back I only
liked him I liked him up until war or
boy or whatever the name of their
[__] albums are I don't even
remember remember that one that had that
[__] creepy looking kid you know look
like the poster for The Grudge like 20
years before it [__] came out like
there's always people like that granted
there are bands that evolve and then
they suck like Jefferson Airplane when
they became Jefferson Starship but I
challenge you to find anything in the
YouTube catalog that comes anywhere near
sucking to the level of we built this
city on rock and roll that is one of the
worst everything you know that they like
when they show some of the worst
dictators and I'm really trying to avoid
to say Adolf Hitler because he becomes
he's become like the hacky reference
when you talk about evil you know and I
really think that that guy is in a lot
of ways overrated when you look at his
number of kills verse Stalin's okay I've
talked about this before Stalin has 20
million confirmed kills okay that's
[__] like what 14 million more 14
million more than Hitler and about
[__] 19 million nine hundred thousand
more than [__] Rambo
okay I'm you know what I'm that's my
that's my thing that's what that's gonna
be my contribution to conversation in
[__] dinner parties you know I'm
gonna start going to those by the way
I'm gonna get a smoking jacket and all
that and when people go like oh my god
he's like the next Hitler and I mean now
he's the next Stalin who's that I don't
know the [__] that of course you don't
you dumb [__] you probably know you know
what Hitler did do you you just Spartan
[__] spouting the [__] out the way I
do every week on the podcast you dumb
[__] speaking of which this is this is a
new part of the podcast it says the
bills dumb bills dumb quote of the week
I had a bunch of people correct me on
something that I've been saying for
years I used the expression I said for
all extensive purposes and somebody
wrote for all extensive purposes it's
not
you don't say it that way and you don't
say it the way most other people say all
intensive purposes it's actually for all
intents and purposes you like that most
people say for all intensive purposes
when they [__] it up bill burr took it
to a whole new level of stupid and said
for all extensive purposes I do that all
the time I say there's something else I
say it has to do with what the [__] is
at the beginning of your college year
when you're a freshman Jesus my memories
just [__] shot I used to always work
those things as a stand-up comic you'd
come in and be like the first why do I
keep thinking salutation that's not what
it is I know it begins with an S though
ah this happens to me like 20 times a
day is there's some sort of fish that I
can be eating to help me with this I
used to do the gigs every year the
beginning of the year incoming freshman
gigs you'd come in and they'd be sitting
there with their parents and my
college-age will be like Billy we got a
we got I got a gig for ya the parents
are gonna be there so make sure you
don't say [__] god dammit I forget but
whatever I used I used to [__] that word
up all the time so whatever so I learned
something it's for all intents and
purposes I used to say hello instead of
pillow PLL oh I'm a [__] [__] and I
don't know why you guys you know what
you [__] I know why you listen to me
you listen to me because my level is
stupidity makes you feel better about
yourself doesn't it huh what does that
say about you you [__] [__] see how
I got out of that by trying to blame you
that's that's that that's a technique I
use am i arguing um but it hasn't wasn't
all bad I actually got I got some Thanks
last week from from a woman it said Bill
uh you were wondering if there are any
Jesus Christ I [__] I copied and
pasted through the wrong one here this
isn't from a woman listen this bill yeah
you were wondering if there were there
are any Jews that listen to your podcast
there are Jews who listen to your
I am one of them and in fact an Orthodox
Jew
I'm not Hasidic I'm not a his civic Jew
but it's the same thing without the
curls dude that's [__] there's got
to be something more than that I know
you just made a joke there what is the
difference between an Orthodox Jew and
it has CITIC Jew I know I could [__]
Google that right now and get some other
morons [__] I'm not saying you're a
[__] but you know what I mean just get
some morons version of what that is I
wasn't even that place I used to go to
down on ninth Avenue it was a best
electronic store and [__] New York
jr's something like that I was like a
block over from Madison Square Garden
yeah were they well now those guys those
guys Orthodox Jews or they Hasidic Jews
I don't know what they were but they
were the [__] they knew about everything
and they had great prices and they
weren't open on Sundays and I respected
that you know somebody's still doing it
the little house in the Prairie way
observing the Sabbath that's one of the
worst things that we've done as a
culture as far as getting away from
religion is we got we got away from a
[__] day off you know this is how old
I am
I remember when [__] malls and all
that [__] were closed on Sundays you
couldn't buy liquor is that still true
can you still not by lucky couldn't buy
beer you couldn't [__] do anything he
just had to sit there and think about
why God was gonna send you to hell you
know but at least you weren't working do
you guys member that little house in the
Prairie episode where [__] Michael
Landon was busting his ass all week and
then they had to go to church on Sunday
and he was so [__] tired he fell
asleep in his church clothes and the
mother looked at him he's like should I
wake him up and she's like god no he's
sleeping like an angel God wouldn't want
me to bring him to church he he should
this is a day of rest he's resting like
the Lord after six days of creating an
universe so the [__] goes to church she
goes to church and when she comes back
this [__] woke up from his little
slumber and he was outside with an ox
and he was plowing the fields again and
all did she get mad at him she really
got mad at him and
that little girls skipped down the hill
and she fell into some shrubs and that
was the end of it and that was another
episode of little house in the Ferrari
let's continue on with the Orthodox
Jewish person's email cuz last week I
was talking about a beanie is that is
that offensive or whatever he said I
wanted to let you know that there is
essentially the yarmulke and yes there
is an R in there but it's sort of silent
is a skullcap as opposed to a beanie
which you were sort of confused about
sort of confused you're being nice here
I'm calling it a beanie should not
insult anyone it's almost the same thing
what is the Pope wear technically it's
called I can't even read with it is a
keto zu c CH e TT o also means skullcap
the real meaning of the yarmulke is yarr
fear of Makka the king and extinct no
Phi's that there is someone up above and
that we are limited moral beings well
what do you mean it's sick okay
doesn't it really signify that there's
someone above that you should be scared
[__] of and that we're limited that's
easy that's the thing that I never liked
about organized religion is the bully
factor I couldn't it's just like why is
this how is God already mad at me I'm
six years old you know what I mean
it just created like if you believe in
this higher power it's this [__]
angry douchebag always looking down at
you pissed off at you you know what I
mean why you [__] mad at me you made
me you know what I mean
if I [__] built a car from ground up
and it didn't run didn't run correctly
who the [__] am I gonna blame the car
that doesn't make any sense
did what'd I just say make any sense I
don't [__] know I like this finish
this umm also you mentioned how the guy
on the plane was wearing a yarmulke so
big you weren't sure if it was a hat or
some sort of giant yarmulke I totally
agree with you I wear a normal-sized
yarmulke and I'm a little annoyed even
when someone wears one so big that it
covers their whole head almost like a
hat
but to each his own I guess anyways a
big fan of comedy in your podcasts well
thank you for listening I appreciate
that you know what I actually have a
theory on those big-time yarmulkes I
think that that is the that's the poor
man's toupee after a while because if he
going bald in the back you start to lose
it in the back like I am a yarmulke is
great because it buys you another three
years of people not knowing that you're
losing your hair see a lot of people
don't realize that Sammy Davis jr. was
actually losing a little bit of his afro
and that's why he converted to Judaism a
lot of people thought it was was a show
business move but it wasn't he was going
bald your hair you heard it here first
so now I'm fascinated what is the
difference between an Orthodox Jewish
person and in his citic Jew what is the
difference and also do you believe in an
afterlife do you believe that God is mad
at you one of the Catholic [__] that I
learned can you eat a cheeseburger on
Friday and I know like all religions you
consider yourselves a hundred percent
right and the chosen one do you guys
have the Notre Dame God loves us best
you know do you have that to that
disease that is in every [__]
religion you shouldn't kill anyone but
God loves us the best and anyone who
doesn't believe what we believe it's
going to he'll have a great week
everybody be sure to pass that on to
people who don't believe in us why does
every character my [__] act talk like
that what did the priest used to sound
like my church
thank you that was my impression of a
Catholic priest alright I've been doing
a lot of ranting and raving on this
podcast people talking about those
little save you know those little scan
cards at the grocery store and somebody
told me that what you're actually doing
is taking a survey and you know to help
them figure out what products you can't
live without so they can jack the price
up and
actually taken that is law so this is
somebody I've had a bunch of different
theories there's another theory a couple
weeks ago you brought up the saver cards
that the storms wondering what the
purpose of and you were wondering what
the purpose of them was you speculated
that it was so they knew what you were
buying to jack up the prices but with
the bard chords bar chords scanning they
already know how much inventory they
move and what sells better than other
things the purpose of the car is to
gather your information to sell it to
mailing lists who then send you junk
mail or spam since they always ask for
an email address they also can be used
as an incentive to keep you going to the
store instead of a competitor ie going
to Macy's instead of JC Penney's they
give you the discount without the card
occasionally so you can be lured into
saving 10 percent or so every time you
go there so they can eventually get your
information Hey your guess is as good as
mine I don't know what they're up to but
I also noticed that most of the [__]
that's on sale is their bootleg version
of the real [__] you don't I mean like
Ralph's olive oil you know I've noticed
that that's another great way like they
could be like okay we're selling the
food what if we made it also you know
and had our own [__] farms I don't
know I just don't like I don't trust
people who are going out of their way to
give me a [__] break
I don't you know what I mean that's like
the [__] Andrew Carnegie kind of like
way of doing [__] you know you [__]
people over your whole life and then the
NDL life you're worried that maybe
really there is a god and then you
become a philanthropist and you start
giving your [__] away
[__] you you sit there with your guilt
I'll pay full price for the peanut
butter thank you very much alright
another theory um what the [__] is this
one this guy says I'm a software
engineer who finished working for a
company that stores and reports on all
sorts of insane sales data some examples
of that type of data they can gather
sales of products based on ethnicity
yeah see this is why I think they also
want the card cuz it's not enough to
know all we sold twenty boxes of Froot
Loops they want to know was it a guy was
it a [__] girl how old were they what
color the main data I saw in this kind
was defined as
Hispanic or non-hispanic I guess that
sales based on ethnicity uh this is a
guy who gathers just data I guess he
says if there was a floor display in
some store what is the effect on the
sales of the item while it the display
what I'm not worst if there is a floor
display in the store what is the effect
on sales of that item while the display
is present let's say for example there
was a NASCAR event sports sponsored by
coca-cola they keep track of coke sales
in that region around the time of that
event furthermore they analyze if the
cost of sponsoring this event made it
that made them enough money to profit to
make it worthwhile sponsoring similar
events this is just a small portion of
wacky [__] they update weekly that was
written in capital letters weekly I
guess that's important weekly they know
every single damn item that was moved
out of each and every store every single
week so basically the stores with the
savvy the savvy saved cards get two huge
benefits they sell this data to my old
company to make money and they let the
consumer feel as they got they have some
kind of superhuman power to save 40
cents when they buy 3 gallons of milk in
one visit so there you go I don't know
you're helping them gather information I
don't like the [__] prick so I'm not
using one um all right now let's get to
the meat of the podcast here people
shall we
I'm doing this on a football [__]
Sunday right now cuz I could give a [__]
about other teams in a league right now
all I give a [__] about right now is my
Patriots sense basically because I've
watched so much [__] hockey this week
that I'm kind of all I'm done with
sports I watched I was flipping back and
forth between the Ohio State Iowa
Hawkeye's game this week and I was also
flipping back between that and the USC
Stanford game and Jesus Christ how about
a moment of silence for the [__] fans
of the USC Trojans who went out to see
that I mean that was a [__] ass rape
and you guys took you know and I'll tell
you right now Trojan fans you have no
[__]
right getting mad at Jim Harbaugh for
going for two points let me let me let
me set this up basically Stanford was up
48 to 21 for those of you overseas
usually you just kick an extra point
right to make it 49 or you can go for a
two-point conversion there's no reason
to go for a two-point conversion when
there's six minutes left and you're up
by four or five scores and they went for
it and the crowd started booing and you
know you gotta understand you guys USC
for the last five years you have been
raping everyone in the pac-10 you bent
him over yeah I mean how many times did
you guys score 50 60 points sent the
other team crying on their little team
bus sent him home crying right well what
goes around comes around
and I became a huge stanford and Jim
Harbaugh a fan but the fact that he went
for two points and then he also in the
end they got the ball back again and he
went for the endzone and they end up
winning 55 to 21 Jim Harbaugh was trying
to literally end the football program at
USC it was one of the most vengeful act
the biggest acts of vengeance I've seen
in sports in a while I [__] loved
every second of it
and I was also watching the the OSU Iowa
Hawkeye's game and those youth fans of
the podcast know that my new tradition
as I go to the Rose Bowl every year so
both of those games were huge I was you
know I really didn't want to see us see
again mainly because you know I like
variety and that fat [__] from last
year's game was a USC fan so I'm happy
that she had a miserable day you know
she probably didn't a hundred percent
she probably you know I had a dozen
doughnuts in front of her so it wasn't a
total loss
really bill 11 months later you still
giving a [__] about her weight yeah I am
and then Iowa you know that [__]
quarterback for Iowa that kids 19 years
old I'll tell you all you long horn fans
sitting there talking about that Colt
McCoy that kid at Iowa's was those are
the [__] plays those are the passes
you have to make to make it on to the
[__] pros all right you have to throw
the same kind of throws that they throw
the NFL level he can't be running the
[__] option and gain in like a
hundred fifty yards a game and then also
throwing for two hundred no one gives a
[__] the second you start running watch
Tim Tebow watch that guy when he goes
into the draft that guy is gonna be the
like I swear if he goes in the second
round it's not gonna surprise me he's a
tight end playing [__] you're not
getting in that Jesus Freak I don't give
a [__] how many Psalms he writes
underneath his [__] eyes is gonna get
laid out in the pro level he's gonna get
[__] laid out i guaran-flat-tee and
then I watched of the Flyers in the
Sabres and I watched the Bruins and the
Penguins game I actually watch the
Penguins game this morning I watch the
[__] recording of it so I'm all I got
nothing left I can't watch any more
[__] sports but I have to watch the
Patriots then I play [__] Magoo in
the Indianapolis Colts and I really hope
the Patriots win because I really want
to hear how Peyton Manning is gonna
figure out how to complain about Bill
Belichick and the Patriots this year
that guy is one of the biggest [__]
babies in the history of the NFL one of
the biggest crybabies in the history of
the [__] NFL they were holding on to
our receivers and I I couldn't get the
ball to him remember that year he cried
about it after the game he made a tape
three weeks later at the Pro Bowl he
cried about it he cried about it all the
way to the draft now if you're ever
watching the NFL and you're wondering
why is it illegal to cover receivers now
it's because of Peyton Manning whining
he wore a diaper from [__] January
until May crying about this [__] game
and then they couldn't run I felt like a
jerk and then what happens they make
this rule where basically you can't
cover a receiver and the very next year
he goes out Natalie
does he break Dan Marino's touchdown
record he shatters it a record that been
around for 20 years you know I had been
around for 20 years I'll tell you why
because you could cover receivers and
Dan Marino was the [__]
that's why Dan Marino owns every [__]
passing record out there except Brett
Favre decided to play till he was 50 you
know Jesus Christ if Dan Marino played
till he was 50 you never you never would
and you couldn't cover receivers that
gate would have [__] throw 90
touchdowns and I hated the guy Patriots
fan he used to kill us all the time and
people still give the guy [__] because
he never won a Super Bowl was he
supposed to do tackle people - you
[__] morons the guy never had a
running back Dan Marino is the greatest
quarterback that I'm a [__] played
the game guy was a beast second year in
the league he throws for like five
thousand yards who does that nobody
nobody does that okay so this
half-retarded Frankenstein is coming in
his big Frankenstein [__] head he's
coming in there to play the Patriots
today I don't know what's gonna happen
you know what's great is I'm recording
this before the game happened so I gotta
I gotta talk some [__] hear what I think
is gonna happen I actually think the
Colts are gonna win I think the Patriots
defense is still it's too new it's too
young and even though Bill Belichick is
a defensive genius and he's slowly
molding them into that suffocating
quote/unquote boring defense that we had
remember that the beginning of the 2000s
when everybody said the Patriots were a
boring team with no stars on it and I
take Peyton Manning over [__] Tom
Brady what's the score three Super Bowls
two one really you'd rather have [__]
one title rather than three well good
luck to you so I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen today but I have
faith I have faith in my boys and I
think we're gonna [__] we're gonna
eke out a victory and I think [__]
Peyton Manning is gonna cry about it and
he's gonna throw his team under the bus
we had we had some protection issues we
had protection your shoe [__] what a
douchebag you know what I mean they
should go have a sword fight with that
[__] idiot kicker his all right there
you go that's my prediction
[Laughter]
anyways was there a prediction in there
yeah my heart saying my heart is saying
that the Patriots are gonna win by three
my brain is telling me that we might
lose by seven just because I just I'd
like I said we have a brand new [__]
defense and it's gonna take them believe
it or not it does take a good year or
two for guys to get used to each other
to know where they're gonna be at you
know to know where you got help and all
that type of [__] so anyways let's
continue on with the podcast Oh let's
get into this shitstorm last week I did
a somebody asked me a question about why
when a guy does something for his
girlfriend why is it never enough and
one of the one of the problems that I've
had and that this guy had last week is
you you try to plan something that both
you and your girlfriend can enjoy as
your night out and evidently women have
a problem when you pick something for
the both of you to do that you as a guy
will also enjoy evidently from what I'm
reading from these [__] psycho emails
that I got this week is that if it's not
100% about them if you don't literally
make a rose bowl [__] float sit them
on it and then drag it down the street
with your [__] teeth they feel that
you got too much an enjoyment out of the
evening so basically the evening was it
was really your evening it was really
look at the [__] wedding day you
stand in it like an idiot and she makes
this grand entrance she gets some
one-of-a-kind dress and you you get a
tuxedo that some [__] drunks gonna
wear at a 15 year anniversary for a
bowling alley the next [__] week you
know what I mean all right let's listen
to what the [__] had to say to this
week all right it is this was this
wonderful girl and I say she's wonderful
because she actually admitted that she
was a psycho cuz I actually emailed her
and asked her why do you only respond to
male female [__] and she sort of in her
own little cute way admitted that she
was a psycho so I can't hate her but
anyways this is her email
hey Bill I love the clueless email
questions from your male listeners
that's always a great way by the way to
get the other people to listen to what
you have to say right out of the gate
just start insulting them and talking
down to them he said the guy was asking
why is it never enough to please a woman
since he admitted he and as she's
referring to his email she says since he
admits he isn't home a lot I'm guessing
his wife / girlfriend is doing all the
dirty work for him his laundry cleaning
cooking picking up after him etc all
right let's stop right there she's doing
all the dirty work let me ask you guys a
question would you rather sit home doing
laundry
first of all laundry is the most
overrated [__] chore ever if you have
laundry in your [__] apartment what
that takes all of a minute to load the
[__] thing in and if you're not
colorblind it probably takes 45 seconds
to load it in and then you go back to
watching The Price is Right cleaning
cooking picking up after him I would
rather do that than do what this other
guys do and this other guy is working
like 60 hours of [__] week okay let's
let's move it she's already made this
assumption okay then she then she wants
him to spend some some time with him and
he comes up with something that he
wanted to do just like when you took
your girlfriend on that drive all we
heard about was the love story between
you and the car you were more excited
about the car than anything it was like
you were on a date with the car and your
girlfriend just came along for the ride
listen back to even the tone in your
voice when you were talking about it
it's like you were talking about another
woman all right you know something I
could sit around for 20 years trying to
come up with the perfect paragraph to
talk how insanely jealous and psychotic
women are can you bless about an
inanimate object she's talking about a
car it's almost like you were talking
about another woman lady you are out of
your [__] mind
you're out of your [__] mind and
you're totally ignoring the fact that I
took her out to dinner I took her out to
lunch I took her up for a ride up to
Pacific Coast Highway
fly out here as a vacation to do that a
lot of couples do that and I'll tell you
right now they don't do it in a Corvette
Convertible they do it in like a [__]
whatever a Buick Century really yeah I
mean it literally is never enough you're
actually proving this guy point this
guy's point so she says my husband does
the same damn thing I'm like what can we
do for fun today slash tonight and the
only thing he can come up with are
things that interest him well what can
you come up with can you come up with
anything that doesn't interest yourself
your selfish [__] you're doing the exact
same [__] thing and it's unbelievably
selfish for you to sit here and and and
have like a day that's for both of you
and it has to be 100% about you because
what you did some laundry you're lazy
[__] your base you know what women are
they're basically they're like adult
children that's what they are they never
get beyond they're like juveniles
they're adults but they still want to be
treated like they're not of age it's
it's just [__] boggles my goddamn
mind she goes I'd rather not do anything
at all
I think it's selfish and ignored and
obnoxious that everything we do has to
have his interests before mine
so everything that they do should have
your interests before his yeah he's
[__] broads there right let's see
this is this is my thing this is why you
should you should never get married you
should never be in a [__]
relationship you shouldn't because they
just constantly [__] hack away at
your goddamn knees and their idea of a
relationship is that you do everything
that they want to do and right now this
sitting there shaking their heads
they're going now now even the girl
wrote that's probably saying no and
there's a bunch of other women going
like I'm not like that I'm not like that
I went to a ping pong convention they
always come up with some stupid ass
[__] example and at the end of the
[__] day you have to do everything
that they do do you have to do what the
[__] they want to do or else they get
mad okay and that my friend is when
jerking off comes into play because when
you really break it down what's the
worst thing that they're going to do to
you they're not
gonna [__] you for a few days okay and I
gotta be honest with you once you'll rub
one out who gives a [__] and you have to
have that clarity when your nuts are
full do you know what I mean am i
sounding like a [__] maniac here I
know I am I know I am but you got you
got two here with them with this with
this of this other woman wrote and of
course I don't have it in front of me
because I'm an idiot where the [__] it
is it alright I am ready to comment on
the why it is never enough discussion on
your last episode episode I'll start by
saying that the guy that wrote in and to
a slightly lesser extent you come off as
total douches
let me explain my view of the writers
the writers situation oh I guess the
guys sent the email and yes I am one of
those manipulative selfish creatures
known as women yeah you are what you
called yourself out on it now suppose or
on was I supposed to like read that and
be like wow I really am too harsh on
women see you're like trying to
manipulate me with your [__] [__]
already okay here we go
I don't remember the names so I'll call
him Bob and his wife Sally Bob neglects
Sally a huge [__] on Bob's part now
let's let's get back to the to the
detail here he's neglecting her what is
he is he out at the bar chasing other
women this guy is out working his
[__] ass off this is the thing that
women don't understand what they don't
understand is I I this is maybe I'm
being a [__] again or a douche as this
lady says I think a lot of women don't
understand what it takes to be
successful what it takes is sacrifice
and in your 20s you have to work your
[__] ass off that's what I did for
five years my first five years in this
[__] business I had no girlfriend I
had no social life I had nothing all I
was doing shows and in [__] rubbing
one out that's what the [__] I did every
goddamn day I went to work I was writing
jokes at work and at night I got in a
piece-of-shit car and I wouldn't
sometimes drive to another [__] state
and you know why I had no girlfriend
during that time cuz none of them could
understand what I had to do to get where
I am today all of them were giving me
[__] you're doing stand-up
again tonight do you realize how many
Richard Pryor's are [__] working at a
home depot or Jimi Hendrix because they
hooked up with the wrong [__] [__]
who talked him out of their goddamn
dream because they didn't want it they
didn't want to hear it because they said
you needed some sort of responsibility
this [__] guy is doing the right
thing and she's calling him selfish he's
at work
busting his ass trying to get ahead so
when he's 40 he's not a [__] loser
and he SC and they all want the [__]
house they all want it [__] yesterday
but they don't want to get through the
[__] of it they don't want to go
through the [__] of it we actually
have to not see him for a little while
cuz he's out working so anyways
huge [__] up on his fart part to be
busting his goddamn ass so he says Bob
decides to make it up to her by taking
her to see your live show she says which
is awesome and a dinner which is pretty
standard this is how out of control
women are she's getting a free [__]
meal and they're so spoiled as a sex
that she's describes a free [__] meal
as standard do you know what I have to
do is a man to get a free meal I have to
like win like a [__] like a radio
contest you know I got to call up this
radio station and imitate the local
sports guy and I have to beat out all
these other [__] guys who are I
haven't had a free meal since I was like
eight years old and my parents took me
to McDonald's or whatever like maybe 13
14 women are so [__] spoiled that
this guy is busting his ass at work
that's viewed as selfish he's buying
this girl a free dinner and it's viewed
is standard they're out of their [__]
minds so anyway she goes Sally basically
tells her friends who may or may not
know that bob has been [__] up once
again bob is [__] up because he's
busting his ass at work so when they're
40 they're gonna be on easy street he's
[__] up right now these same [__]
who make you [__] you know not chase
your dream leave you when you're 38
because you're a [__] loser right all
right
I love generalizing it really gets these
[__]
[__] hairs in a [__] I know I can't
even finish that sentence that was so
evil alright let's play flower head who
may or may not know that bob has been
[__] up that this night out is not
what she had in mind but she is taking
what she can get playing the victim ah
the poor baby
she's taking what she got a free meal
she's just taking what she can get and
she's getting a show to come out to my
show one of the best [__] comedians
in the country you like that I'm talking
[__] it's football Sunday and I'm a plus
I'm reading the Ric Flair the best comic
on the biggest hill
anyways Bob gets upset and determines
that no one has ever or will ever be
able to please any female code for why
should he even make an effort to make
his wife happy in their marriage
that's not code for that that's how you
read into it you've never met Bob you've
made all kinds of assumptions here
poor poor Bob Bob's douchery becomes a
crystal becomes crystal clear when he is
when he says something to the effect of
this whole night outs was supposed to be
about her this is quite this is classic
male priviledge Wang Curie but I realize
this is hard for you and Bob to see so
I'm here to help I'll try to make it
simple when you piss off your wife bring
her along to a show you already wanted
to go to and that she is only mildly
interested in then being a little
scrotum about it when she's is
underwhelmed by the fact that you are
actually making an effort to go out with
her which is what you should have been
doing as a matter of course is not the
way to go oh my god I mean the arrogance
in this I love people who are arrogant
they're calling you out for being
arrogant bringing you to a show do you
understand like I'm gonna stop being a
jerk here because maybe I can actually
convince a couple women do you
understand what it takes this is well
actually you know I've been generalizing
there are women out there who understand
what it takes to become successful and I
guarantee you most of them are not in
relationships and they have a difficult
time being in relationships you know
because the guy they're with wants to go
home and play [__] footsie or wants
her around and doesn't understand that
these are the
years where she has to bust her ass to
get where the [__] she's gonna be you
know so lady both you guys are a hundred
percent wrong I could see if this guy
was out drinking with his buddies if
this guy was out [__] around on her
or if he was just sitting there staring
at the TV watching football not paying
attention to her when he brings her out
yeah then I could see that he should
have some sort of mini all about you
wedding day for her okay but if this guy
is busting his ass it [__] work okay
he's not going out having a good time
either so he should be allowed to have
some sort of enjoyment you understand he
should be able to enjoy some of the day
some of the night also and there's
another thing that you haven't even
brought up how much of the rent do you
think he's [__] paying I'd be willing
to bet that he's paying more than she is
a lot of guys are in that situation too
when you get this the adult child
version of a [__] woman I'm telling
you you women I'm telling you the two
who wrote in you're way out of line on
this one I'm not even trying to be funny
right now you're a hundred percent in
the [__] wrong here you're being
selfish beyond [__] selfish this guy
is at work he's busting his ass trying
to get ahead do you think this guy wants
to [__] work 60 hours a week
nobody dreams about doing that why do
you think he's doing that he's trying to
become successful you know so the next
time you're gay you know like I said if
this guy had been [__] around or if
this guy had been sitting there watching
you know sports and not paying attention
to you and hadn't given you a compliment
since you could [__] remember yeah
then I could understand you know what I
mean taking you to the whatever the [__]
you wanted to go to but for you to sit
there and this guy spends his
hard-earned [__] money takes you out
to dinner okay
which you got understand is not standard
okay and yo how [__] spoiled are you
that you think that that is stare is
standard I got the [__] hiccups here
I'm so goddamn upset you guys are you
guys 100% wrong and if any new broads
out there one I want to try to come out
and support these two girls I mean go
for it because I don't see how they're
wrong this guy did nothing wrong he took
her out to go see a show
it's justyou know what is stand-up
comedy is not respected it isn't if he
took you out to see a Broadway show or a
[__] musical or I guess that's the
same thing I don't know what I guess if
he took you out for dinner and a movie I
love I like like guys always have to
show some sort of imagination it's
standard it was just imagination we like
surprises and it's like when was the
last time your girl actually showed any
[__] imagination when they got you a
shirt you know or some sports DVD you
know do they ever really show any sort
of [__] imagination I'll tell you it
does my girl she actually showed some
imagination one year when I first met
her I uh I was playing drums you know
she knew I was into drums she knew I
loved him and she actually got me this
despair of drums she got me a pair of
drumsticks we'd only been going on for
like a month so there was like that
thing you can't get a really huge gift
but you got to get him something she got
me a pair of drumsticks and she had my
my initials engraved in him I never even
used him I thought it was really it was
unique it was loving it wouldn't know
and it didn't cost her that much money
and it was totally [__] cool I
wouldn't be like well you know it's you
got to do that every birthday you know
surprise me like you did with the
drumstick 6 X spend a ton of [__]
money to you know I don't know if that
even [__] I think I started to make
one point then I made another one in
that when I'm so [__] annoyed by
these these women did that they they
were out of their [__] minds you're
out of your [__] minds ok if the guy
who wrote that email last week don't
listen to these [__] [__] alright
you but you're out there you're busting
your goddamn ass you have to sit down
and you have to explain to your wife or
your girlfriend or whatever the [__] she
is what it takes to become successful
because I'm telling you you understand
what it is you're doing what everybody
else did in their 20s all those people
out there you know the Broads with the
[__] stamps and the guys with the
tribal band tattoo who are out there
doing keg stands and [__] everything
that moves doing their best to catch
herpes every [__] weekend those
people they wonder what happens when
their get to their thirties and their
40s they wonder what the [__] happened
you know and they're looking at you like
you
[__] you know now the payoff is is
usually when you become successful you
end up renting a Corvette at 41 having
sort of a mini midlife crisis but I'm
telling you I'd rather be me than those
other [__] dudes
I really would so you really need to
explain to this woman who looks at you
busting your ass as neglect as as being
selfish is just beyond me
it's [__] beyond you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing as a man is
a man is supposed to work and he's
supposed to provide for his family and
what you were doing is you are laying
the groundwork for you to do that as
best as you possibly can and for someone
to say that that is selfish is just
[__] beyond me okay let me ask you
this when you went out that night how
[__] tired were you how many times
did you yawn from working all [__]
week you know what I mean you know
aren't you allowed to go out and have a
good time with your girlfriend with a
little bit of [__] that she enjoys a
little bit of stuff that you enjoy isn't
that like a [__] relationship I mean
my out of my [__] mind here anyways
this is really just become a woman
bashing thing that's really just [__]
tapped into this here's another email I
got bill this this got me so pissed off
and I swear the first thing that came to
my mind was wait till bill hears this
[__] I guess I listened to your show too
much so here's the story he goes I went
on my lunch break with the female
co-worker today and the the true mind of
a female really shined I'm telling you
women you really got a chime in here and
trash guys because this has really
become and this is like like the guys
this week are Stanford and women are
[__] USC but uh whatever watch Oprah
he always went on that show here we go
first off I'm not interested in this
female we are just friends we have we've
even talked about this and I have
explained to her and we agree nothing is
happening there no problem so we go out
to get a sandwich and her ATM account is
frozen
she calls the bank and they think
something's wrong and won't give her the
money till they talk tomorrow
right there [__] the banks right exactly
you can't even get your own [__]
money provided she's not over drunk so
here we go so he goes I would have lent
her the cash but I was broke I offered
to give her all the money all the money
in my pocket about two dollars and fifty
cents in pocket change that would at
least bought her a coffee I already paid
for my sandwich when we found out about
the ATM so she turns down that but asked
me to drive her a few blocks to go to
the bank and I happily do that doesn't
work and we have to go back to work this
is all during your lunch hour she asked
me to borrow a credit card or something
to get food I don't have any so she
can't so she calls back the job and asks
another guy for five bucks he says yes
she then asked me for the 250 she turned
down before I said sure now here is the
[__] kicker so now this girl has 750
she then tells me word for word well
since I got five bucks now let me tell
you something and with this fake grin on
her face
trying to soften the blow actress she
wasn't she's going into [__] mode here
she goes if you were in this Jam I would
have offered you half of my sandwich but
that's okay I'm just saying and the guy
said I was floored I was like yo first
off you only said this after you got the
money because you knew how it might make
me feel and now you have my money and
don't need my sandwich so basically you
just wanted to make me feel shitty for
not living up to your standard of
friendship she laughed it off and said
she was trying to offend me she wasn't
trying to offend me and let it go
[__] you called her out on her [__]
notice how she waited till she got you
250 and then did the little [__]
two-point reversal on you then she
brings it up again and now I realize she
was really bothered by the fact I didn't
offer her the sandwich I bought with my
last five bucks to my name meanwhile she
she has 400 bucks in the bank
they just won't give it to her tomorrow
she will be fine I will still be broke
yet she still thinks I should have given
her half of the last sandwich I can for
a week till I get paid the thing that
gets
me the most is we work a Labour job I'm
always helping her lift and move things
because she herself brings up the point
she is a girl yet she talks all the time
about how men and women are are equal in
the workplace and she should be treated
the same and this isn't some dumb [__]
she went to school for four years got a
degree changed her mind and now she's
going back to get another degree that
will take her six more year years she
reads and studies all day and I enjoy
her conversations because she smarts but
at the end of the day I have learned she
is still a woman and she still feels she
should somehow be babied by other men
simply because she is a woman I'm not
sleeping with her we are just friends
why do you feel entitled to half of my
last even if after I go out of my way on
half of my sandwich even if after I go
out of my way every way I can to help
you exactly you went you gave her every
last cent in your [__] pants you
drove her down to the bank you drove her
back to work this was all during your
[__] lunch hour you're lifting her
boxes and all that type of [__] I mean I
don't know I don't know what to tell you
I mean maybe you could have given her
half your [__] sandwich I don't know
what your relationship is with her but
that's the classic you know I could see
if she got the five dollars out of the
other guy you know and didn't take you
to 50 but she gets to five and then
takes you to 50 and then brings it up
you know what I mean
I'm telling you do write that like if
someone did that to me I would be done
with them I would be done with them I
wouldn't tell him that I would be done
with him what I would do it was I would
wait for the next time she needed me to
lift something I would do a [__] I smile
back to her and be like you know if I
was asking you I would make sure that I
would live half the box with me you know
or whatever the [__] you want to say
anyways he said thanks for letting me
vent
sign the Jewish dude alright let's see
here I think that might be a that it
that's it right I think that is it that
is it for the podcast all right well let
me say let me state for the record here
I don't know
after the second time reading that maybe
you could have given her half you saying
or part of your sandwich offered her a
bite but you know you spent all your
[__] money then she finds out she's
[__] broke but that is the typical
female [__] thing okay we're equal
Rico rescue me
rescue me we're equal we're equal rescue
me they basically they ride that fence
okay and what most of them do is when
it's a good thing to be equal then
you're equal and when it's a bad thing
to be equal like you know I have to pick
up something heavy then then it's like
oh I'm just a girl you know or dinner
comes along and the check comes along
then I'm a female you should be a
gentleman I did a bit about this a long
[__] time ago so basically they can't
hurt me what are they doing that's wrong
there they're just trying to manipulate
it's the the situation to their
advantage all you have to do is a guy
just be conscious of it and call him out
on this [__] you should have asked for
your 250 back when she said no he should
have demonstrated your strength as a man
tipped her upside down and shook it out
of her that's it that's it for the
monday morning podcast that was kind of
dark that was kind of evil is kind of
ugly and I anticipate a lot of emails
but that's how the podcast goes
sometimes and I know it wasn't on a cell
phone but go [__] yourself that's how
I'm doing them that's how I'm gonna
continue doing them if you don't like it
[__] go listen to the old ones go
listen to the old bunch of pricks this
week I'm gonna be at the improv in Tempe
Arizona all right I'm gonna be there on
Thursday Friday and Saturday and there's
been a little switcheroo on my schedule
I was supposed to be going to Seattle I
was supposed to be going to Seattle to
play giggles comedy club but
unfortunately that comedy club does not
advertise so the only way I sell tickets
is to go on this one particular radio
show and they changed the format and got
rid of my hookup up there so there's no
way for me to go into town to let
anybody know that I'm gonna be there so
the club owner would just lose a ton of
[__] money so like a class guy I
switched out the date okay so basically
I think I'm gonna be maybe doing Seattle
in January so instead of going to
giggles in Seattle I will be at the
punchline in Sacramento California
punchline Sacramento California on
December 10th 11th and 12th and 13th and
the week before that I will be at
hilarities in Cleveland go to bill burr
combi you are are for all the dates and
I can't believe I forgot to mention this
at the top of the podcast tickets are on
sale for my next stand-up one hour
stand-up comedy special it's gonna be at
the Fillmore on December 17th in San
Francisco California if you would like
to come [__] I don't have any [__]
information I am a goddamn horse do I
have the link I don't have the link of
my website I am the [__] worse go to
Live Nation calm that's where the
tickets are being sold just type in Bill
burr December 17th at the Fillmore you
will be able to find it or you can join
my mailing list because I know I sent
out a I sent out information about that
I'm the worst alright I'll have all the
information next week I'll be putting a
bulletin up on my my bill burr comm on
my myspace page oh and the other thing I
forgot to tell you as I have uninformed
radio.com is the new website for the
uninformed show I believe that's it let
me try and once again I'm the [__]
worst I don't have any of the
information hang on a second [__]
voice is going way up here hang on
everybody who are fans of the uninformed
show with bill burr and Joe DeRosa
everybody has asked me for the longest
times where can I get the shows what do
we do okay
uninformed radio.com uninformed
radio.com if you go there you can
download all the shows and they're gonna
be for free so if you'd like to hear
more of me running my [__] mouth you
can go there uninformed radio.com that
is it all you guys have
we can talk to you this Monday and we
may well as well
de Foix is upon me
Parma well the nail on me Jamie Shaw
said he fought up it GD Frizzle black
Ted Othello in the lab women shut rapper
b.o.b annyeong so so till mom does it
bassoon or they will have me
patitos you see do razor to shave too
son recommended you jet Ola visual on me
each other poses kill you public don't
say Kody but we don't care because you
know they tell a better cook where my
world you eat - Tom be solid
[Music]
you